오늘도 새벽의 남자 김단태가 왔습니다.
트럼프의 데드라인 때문에 지금 시장이 매우 긴장하고 있죠.
한국 시간으로는 4월 8일 오전 9시가 트럼프가 얘기한 데드라인입니다.
물론 트럼프가 협상이 진행되는 경우에 데드라인을 뒤로 미룰 수 있다고 얘기해둔 상태이긴 하지만
어쨌든 데드라인이 지금 한 촬영 시간 기준으로 5시간밖에 안 넘었고요.
이란이 미국의 요구를 들어주지 않을 시에 문명을 말살하겠다라는
극단적인 표현까지 하면서 트럼프가 이 협상을 강하게 밀어붙이고 있어요.
문명을 말살한다라는 극단적인 표현을 하다 보니까
미국 내에서도 이런 트럼프의 협상 방식에 대해서 상당히 비판을 받고 있는 상황이고
어쨌든 현재 이란은 알려진 바에 따르면 미국과의 직접 통신을 차단하고 있습니다.
다만 여전히 중재자를 통한 협상은 진행 중인 것 같습니다.
그리고 이슬람혁명수비대 같은 경우에 이런 식으로 트럼프가 공격을 할 경우에는
중동의 석유나 가스 인프라 등으로 공격을 하면서 대응을 하겠다라고 하고
트럼프가 SNS에 쓴 표현을 보면 문명이 사라질 것이다 라는 식으로 표현을 했어요.
그런데 이게 도대체 정확하게 어떻게 공격을 한다는 건지에 대해서는 좀 모호한데
다만 트럼프가 민간 공격 혹은 인프라 공격 이런 것들도 충분히 할 수 있다고 보고 있다 보니까
공화당 내부에서도 반발하는 그런 얘기가 나오고 있고
민주당에서는 좀 더 극단적으로 더 많이 걱정을 하고 있습니다.
그래서 척슈먼은 트럼프 보고 매우 병든 사람이다 라고 비판을 하면서
전쟁 종식 표결을 해야 되는 거 아니냐 뭐 이런 얘기도 있고
우파로 알려져 있는 팟캐스터인 터커 칼슨도
민간인 살상 공격 시도는 좀 저지해야 되는 거 아니냐 이런 얘기를 하고 있으면서
정말 분위기가 극단적으로 가고 있고요.
그리고 시장 현재 상황을 좀 보면 나스닥이 1% 하락하고 있고
다우지수 0.83% 하락했고
S&P500도 0.78% 하락을 했습니다.
그러니까 뭐 좋은 게 없죠.
왜냐하면 이제 곧 몇 시간 뒤에 충돌의 그 시간이 오기 때문에
이거에 대해서 시장이 매우 겁을 내고 있다라고 보시면 되고
그러다 보니까 이제 WTI 같은 경우는 조금 더 상승을 했습니다.
브렌트유는 거의 똔똔인 상황이고요.
그래서 지금 이 극한 갈등에 대한 저의 생각
맨날 틀려서 민망하지만
제가 그냥 생각을 했을 때는 크게 바뀌는 건 없을 것 같아요.
그러니까 무슨 말이냐면
이란이 일단 협상을 추락할 것 같지는 않습니다.
왜냐하면 일단 미국의 태도도 너무 마음에 안 들 것 같고
서로 조건이 지금 너무 안 맞는 상황이기 때문에
제가 보기에 이 협상을 추락하지는 않을 것 같고요.
다만 이란이 협상을 거부하더라도
저는 트럼프 또한 아무것도 안 할 것 같습니다.
트럼프가 약간 뭐 타코스러운 경향이 있기 때문에
제가 보기에 또 이렇게 여론에서 강한 공격에 대한 거부감들이 있는 이런 상황에서
굳이 트럼프가 공격을 하진 않고
어떤 핑계를...
트럼프를 대면서 이 데드라인을 미루는 형태로 가는 게
가장 가능성이 높지 않을까
뭐 저는 그렇게 생각을 하는데
저의 희망이 좀 섞여 있을 수도 있지 않나
라는 것도 들으면서 감안을 해 주시면 좋을 것 같고요.
매수매도에 대한 추천 절대 아니라는 거 말씀드리고
자 그리고 오늘은 레이달리오 글을 좀 갖고 와봤습니다.
뭐 맨날 전쟁 얘기 뭐 이렇게 저렇게 된다라는 것 좀 지겨워서
조금 더 거시적인 측면에서도 한번 우리가 생각을 해보면 좋을 것 같고
제가 예전에도 레이달리오에 대해서 많이 얘기를 했었죠.
세계에서 가장 큰 해치펀드인 브릿지워터를 창업했던 사람이고
요즘은 이제 은퇴를 해가지고
여러 가지 자기가 쓰고 싶은 글들을 쓰고 있는데
최근에 레이달리오의 글대로 뭔가 세계 정세가 흘러가는 것 같아서
우리가 그 글이 어떤 내용이 있는지 한번 볼 필요가 있겠죠.
달리오가 몇 시간 전에 새로운 글을 썼습니다.
자 달리오의 글은
이미 세계대전이 시작됐다 라는 그런 글이에요.
일단은 달리오가 보기에는
이미 세계에서 벌어지는 전쟁들이 하나로 연결되어 있다라는 주장을 합니다.
그러니까 러시아와 우크라이나가
우크라이나 전쟁으로 겉으론 보이지만
결국엔 또 이게 유럽과 미국으로도 연결이 되어 있고
지금 또 이스라엘 가자 레바논 전쟁 끝났다고 보기 어렵죠.
뭐 그런 갈등이 있고
예멘 수단 사우디 간의 전쟁도 있고
그리고 가장 최근에 이스라엘과 이란 간의 전쟁이지만
또 이거를 넓혀보면 미국과 또 걸프에 있는 국가들까지
껴있는 그런 전쟁이라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
그래서 이 각각의 전쟁을 개별 전쟁으로 볼 게 아니라
자기가 보기에는 과거
서로 연결된 하나의 큰 전쟁으로 봐야
앞으로 어떤 일이 벌어질지 알 수 있다라는 그런 얘기를 하는 거 같아요.
그런데 가만히 보면 이 전쟁에서 진영이 나뉘고 있습니다.
한 진영은 바로 미국 쪽 진영이고
다른 한쪽은 중국과 러시아 쪽 진영입니다.
그래서 이렇게 두 진영이 나뉘고 있고
이것을 주목해야 되는데
또 한 가지 주목할 건
뭐 이번에 이 전쟁에서 생각보다 중국이 타격이 별로 없다라는 겁니다.
호르무즈 해협을 봉쇄한다라고 해도
중국은 별로 타격이 없다라는 거 달리오가 강조를 하고 있습니다.
어떻게 보면 중국도 전쟁을 할 수 있는 그런 상황이다
라는 얘기를 하기 위해서 중국이 별 타격이 없다 없다라는 얘기를 한 거 같아요.
왜냐하면 중국은 이란으로부터 석유를 공급받을 수도 있고
러시아로부터 받을 수도 있고 석유 비축량도 꽤 되기 때문입니다.
그래서 현재 벌어지고 있는 이 전쟁에서 중국과 러시아가 상대적 승자라고 얘기를 하고 있고요.
이런 상황에서 달리오는 세계 질서가 무너질 때 13단계로 어떤 현상들이 일어나는데
지금이 9단계에 와있다라고 합니다.
제가 전부 다 설명드릴 순 없고
어쨌든 세계 질서가 무너질 때 9단계가 어디냐면
다중의 전선이 동시에 충돌하는 현상인데
지금 딱 봐도 맞는 부분은 있긴 한 거 같아요.
다중의 전선, 여러 전선이 동시에 충돌하고 있는 상황인 건 맞는 거 같고
이런 상황 속에서 미국이 상당히 취약하다라는 겁니다.
미국이 지금 전 세계에 너무나 많은 군사기지가 있고
그리고 또 여러 개의 전선을 동시에 감당하기는 어렵겠죠.
지금 이미 이란, 이스라엘 이 싸움 때문에 사실상 우크라이나 거의 손 놓고 있잖아요.
그래서 그런데 여기서 만약에 하나의 전선이 또 추가가 된다고 하면
미국은 과연 제대로 참여할 수 있을까?
뭐 참여하기가 어렵다라고 생각할 수가 있겠죠.
그리고 또한 민주주의의 특성상 장기전의 고통을 감내하기는 어려울 거다라는 겁니다.
그래서 이런...
취약한, 미국이 취약한 이 상황에서 아시아에서 만약에 사건이 터지면
예를 들어서 대만이라든가 남중국해라든가 이런 곳에서 사건이 터지면
미국이 어떻게 반응할지 전 세계가 지켜보고 있다라는 겁니다.
각국은 미국이 우리를 진짜 지켜줄 수 있는지에 대해서 다시 한번 계산을 해보겠죠.
그러면서 달리우는 수치화하는 걸 참 좋아하는 거 같아요.
향후 5년간의 주요 전쟁의 발생 확률에 대해서 쓰고 있습니다.
참고로 북한은 충돌이라는 표현을 하긴 했어요.
전쟁이라고 보고 있지는 않은 것 같고
뭐 북한이 어쨌든 뭔가 무력시위 같은 거를 하는 걸로 보고 있는 것 같죠.
충돌이라는 표현을 썼기 때문에
어쨌든 이 네 가지 전쟁에 대해서 발생 확률을 봤는데
우크라이나 확전은 확률을 30에서 40%로 보고 있고
가장 달리우의 논리의 핵심에 있는 건 대만 전쟁에 대해서 가장 좀 강조를 하고 있습니다.
그래서 대만 전쟁은 30에서 40%로 보고 있고
40%고 2028년에 최대 위협이 될 거다라고 보고 있고
북한 관련돼서도 어쨌든 얘기를 하고 있어요.
40에서 50%
아 그래요?
그리고 남중국해에서 미국과 중국, 필리핀이 충돌할 확률도
30%로 보고 있는데
자기가 보기에 향후 5년 내에
이 중에 하나라도 발생할 확률은 50%는 넘지 않냐
이런 얘기를 하고 있는 겁니다.
그래서 달리오는 이 작금의 상황이 매우 걱정이 된다라는
그런 얘기를 하고 있고요.
특히 대만 전쟁에 대해서 조금 더 설명을 해보자면
이미 중국은 꽤 많은 미사일을 실전 배치를 했고
신하 미국의 기지나 함정들이
제1도련선 안에서는 극히 취약하다라는 거죠.
마침 또 지금 미국이 이란 전쟁 때문에
군사랑 재정 자원을 소진하고 있죠.
그러면 이것은 중국 입장에서
기회가 열렸다라고 볼 수 있지 않냐라는 거죠.
다만 당장 직접적인 군사 충돌까지는
좀 문턱이 있다.
라는 얘기를 하고 있지만
그럼에도 불구하고
1, 2년 뒤에는 이런 것들이 충분히 가능할 수도 있다라고
얘기를 하고 있습니다.
그 외에도 달리오가 북한에 대해서도 이야기를 했는데
북한에 대해서는 뭔가 전쟁이라기보다
충돌 같은 식으로 돌려 얘기하긴 했습니다.
어쨌든 북한이 미국에 맞서서 싸울 의지가 있고
미사일이 불완전하지만 5년 내에 개선이 될 수 있고
또한 중국과 러시아의 효과적인 대리인이 될 수 있다.
이런 얘기를 했습니다.
이런 얘기를 하기는 했어요.
그래서 군사 충돌이 가능하다.
또 처음에 전쟁인 줄 알고 열심히 읽어봤는데
그나마 충돌이라고 얘기를 하는 것 같고
사실 전면전 정말 뭐라 모르겠어요.
너 죽고 나 죽자로 가지 않는 이상
남한과 북한이 싸움이 되지 않는 체급이라고 저는 생각을 하거든요.
그래서 이성적으로 생각한다면 그렇긴 한데
전쟁이라는 게 늘 이성만이 있지는 않는 거다 보니까
걱정이 되는 부분이 저도 솔직히 있긴 하고요.
사실은 북한 얘기를 해서 저도 이 글을 다 읽어보게 되긴 했어요.
뭐 북한까지 이야기를 하긴 했는데
달리오가 얘기하는 핵심은 바로 이거 같아요.
그러니까 강한 나라가 전쟁을 멈추는 게 아니라
약해 보이는 나라가 전쟁을 확전시키는 건데
지금 미국이 약해 보인다라는 거죠.
이 이란도 지금 쩔쩔매고 있으면
다른 나라들이 봤을 때
야 지금이 기회다라는 생각을 할 거고
새로운 도발을 하면서 확전이 될 수 있다라는
그런 얘기를 하는 거고요.
그래서 달리오가 가장 걱정하는 시나리오는
미국이 이란 전쟁을 멈추고 있는 것.
이란 전을 계속 대응을 해요.
이 이란 전쟁도 상당히 길어질 수도 있다라는
얘기들이 많잖아요.
근데 이런 상황에서 아시아에서 만약 사건이 발생을 하면
미국이 두 가지 전선을 동시에 대응하기 어려워할 것이며
결과적으로 한쪽 동맹을 포기하면
도미노로 분쟁이 될 수 있는 곳들에서
문제가 발생할 것이다 라는 거죠.
달리오 얘기는 대략 이런 정도로 결론을 마칠 수는 있는데
저도 달리오 의견에 반박을 할 수 있는
여지들도 많다고 생각을 합니다.
그래서 클로드한테 물어보니까
클로드가 반박하는 부분들이 바로 이런 건데
예를 들면 세계대전이라고 프레이밍하는 것 자체가 과장이다 라는 거죠.
왜냐하면 세계 1차 대전, 2차 대전과 비교하면
포함되어 있는 나라가
그 세계대전에 포함된 나라들이
산업 생산력 전체를 전쟁에 동원하고 있는 총력전이었는데
지금은 미국이나 중국 같은 나라들이
생산력 전체를 전쟁에 동원하고 있는 건 아니잖아요.
그런 걸로 봤을 때는 좀 과장으로 볼 수 있는 영역은
표현이 과장이라고 볼 수 있는 부분은
있는 것 같고
또 핵이 갖고 있는 억제력을 과소평가하고 있다라고 봅니다.
그래서 핵 보유국끼리 직접 전쟁한 사례가
단 한 번도 없거든요.
1945년 이후에는
왜냐하면 만약에 핵 보유국끼리 싸우면
양측 모두 문명이 끝난다는 걸 알고 있기 때문이죠.
그래서 이런 가능성이 여전히 이 핵 억제력은 그대로라는 겁니다.
그리고 중국과 러시아가 승자라고 분석을 하지만
사실
또 생각해보면 애매한 부분이 있습니다.
왜냐하면 중국 경제가 큰 피해를 보지 않는 건 맞는데
현재 중국 경제도 그렇게 정상은 아니거든요.
부동산 위기도 있고 디플레이션도 심각한데다가
청년 실업까지 있어서 내부가 흔들리는 게 사실인데
이런 상황에서 만약에 중국이 대만의 전쟁을 시작한다?
그러면 이제 중국은 주요 수출 시장이라고 할 수 있는
유럽이나 미국과의 관계를 완전히 끊어야 할 텐데
이거는 정말 중국 입장에서도
이거는 정말 중국 입장에서도 경제에 매우 큰 영향을 받는 것 같아요.
그래서 중국의 입장에서도 적대 진영, 미국의 적대 진영 입장에서도
확전을 원하지 않을 유인이 충분히 있다라는 거고
레이달리오가 말하는 사이클은 결국에는 지나고 나서 하는 얘기 아니냐
그런 얘기를 비판을 했고 저도 뭐 비슷한 생각입니다.
그래서 저도 이런 달리오의 의견에 반박을 할 수 있음에도 불구하고
분명히 이번 사건을 통해서 미국이 종이호랑이다라는 생각이 국제사회에 깔리면
어쨌든 새로운 확전을 불러입고
불러일으킬 수 있는 리스크가 더 커진다라는 거
달리오가 말하는 방향성에 대해서는 좀 어느 정도 동의를 할 수밖에 없지 않나라는 생각을 가지고 있고요.
이 이란 이슈의 장기화가 분명히 다른 군사적 충돌을 불러일으킬 수 있지 않나라는 생각
물론 확률을 얘기하면 달리오보다는 저는 더 낮은 확률로 생각을 하고 있긴 한데
어쨌든 이런 방향성 자체는 우리가 한번 생각해 볼 만한 것 같아서
한번 여러분들한테 소개를 시켜드리고 싶습니다.
자 그럼 저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고 투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 설명란 고정 댓글 참고 부탁드립니다.